and that is with us in Charlotte
Virginia high on that welcome to Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave thank you for taking
my call sure I had had a question we're
on baby SEP 7 we've done your program
and we were debt-free in June and my
husband's getting a little bit we've
gotten some inheritance from his father
and we're getting the last little bit
and I was just wanting to see what your
feeling would be if we took it it's
about $20,000 and use that toward a
vacation or he and I you're in baby step
seven your house is paid for how much
how much is in your nest egg
we have about three hundred thousand in
our retirement right now and we have
about thirty six thousand and our
emergency funds and how much is your
home worth about 450 okay so you're
almost millionaires we're working on it
we're a little bit we're in our 50s /
late what's your household or investing
what's your house shopping 200 200
definitely we go on that vacation okay
you have like a great you have lived
like no one else and now you're going to
live like no one else okay just wanted
to make sure and see what you thought on
that yeah thank you here's the thing
okay it doesn't it doesn't change your
future okay if it changed your future I
would say no I would recommend against
it but it doesn't change your future
you're making $200,000 a year you don't
have a payment in the world your house
is paid for you've already got you're in
your 50s you've already got 300,000 and
your 401 KS you're gonna double that
triple that in the next six years and
that alone okay so by the time you hit
60 you're gonna have over a million
dollars in your 401ks and in your mutual
funds you have a house that's paid for
that's worth a half a million dollars
and you've been making 200k if you don't
do that then you've been pretty lazy and
you're not lazier you wouldn't be
calling me from the position you're in
okay so there are three things we can do
with money we can give it we can invest
it and we can enjoy it and you ought to
always be willing to do all three all
right enjoy we're headed for vacation
for you are you going we probably go
into Europe we like to do the river
cruises we're thinking about when we
thought of that twenty thousand dollars
worth of that's first class but we're
looking at two weeks at least two weeks
so you're gonna step on it and go get
the big suite good for you enjoy that's
fine that's a fun trip open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I like taking those calls
occasionally just to put it in some of
your faces that think that Dave Ramsey
is synonymous with cheap I'm cheap so
that I don't have to be cheap I want you
to live like no one else so later you
can go on vacation like no one else
I can guarantee you Sharon frickin
ramsey goes on first-class vacations and
she's earned every penny of it putting
up with me for 37 years and you know
what we you know and some of you don't
think I ought to spend that money you
know what it's not in your dadgum
business is my money God didn't give it
to you to manage she gave it to me to
manage in part of what my Heavenly
Father wants me to do is enjoy part of
it is he wants me to think about legacy
in the future and part of it is he wants
me to be outlandish outlandish ly
generous outrageously generous and I'll
guarantee you I do all three with gusto
invest in joy and generosity and they're
all in the scriptures